we're looking for a very windy couple of
days so really hope you take some time
to prepare
maybe secure loose items around your
patio your yard i think we're going to
see a lot of flying dust
elevated dust and lots of debris on the
roads etc
here after later today and definitely
into thursday
temperatures have been very mild this
morning got lots of 70s out there very
comfortable
some upper 60s now centennial hills
summerlin to the lakes uh
red rocks at 68 and 69 up there at
aliante kyle canyon of 54
starting to feel a little bit of a
breeze already in the middle of town
we're going to be hot though again today
in those upper 90s you'll be running the
ac
and we'll start to see those breezy and
feel those gusty southwest winds through
the afternoon into tonight
and stronger winds tomorrow maybe up to
45 miles an hour
wind advisories have been issued for
tomorrow and then we'll cool down behind
this system
temperatures dropping to the mid 70s by
friday and you know what that means that
means
cooler mornings for a while too heading
into your weekend it's all because of
this front
that's poised to the north of us but
eventually will work its way through our
area
later tomorrow all these areas of red
i'm going to zoom in
focus on clark county but the
surrounding areas too
are under this fire weather warning
which take effect at 11 o'clock this
morning
go all the way until friday morning low
humidity dry gusty winds a very
dangerous combination
if a fire gets started it's going to
spread very quickly
and then wind advisories for our area
all of clark county southern nye county
start at 11 o'clock tomorrow morning
until 8 o'clock in the evening
as those winds increase and get stronger
that's really going to be hazardous
especially for driving but
could really blow things around in your
neighborhood as well so be careful
97 still very hot today tomorrow
temperatures slide into the mid 80s
and then really take a dive to the mid
70s on friday look at these morning
temperatures
down in the 50s you'll probably be
reaching for some long sleeves when you
head outdoors
a light jacket slowly we get back to
some low 80s by sunday what a beautiful
spring weekend
and then hotter 90s again next week